for the first time a military judge has
allowed a terror detainee to speak on
the record about the cia's secret
prisons and post-9 11 interrogation
program 41 year old majeed khan a
pakistani citizen who graduated from a
maryland high school told a military
court at guantanamo bay yesterday about
brutal tactics that critics call torture
we should warn you the evidence is
graphic and may be disturbing for some
of you senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge as at
the pentagon catherine good morning
good morning khan wore a dark suit and
sat unshackled in court yesterday's
hearing went late into the evening and
at the end khan read a 39 page statement
claiming he was sexually assaulted and
nearly drowned by his c.i.a
interrogators who he said threatened to
rape his sister
two years after 9 11 admitted al-qaeda
member majid khan was captured in
pakistan before a flight to a secret cia
prison khan said my clothes were cut off
and i was stripped nude and held down
next the americans forcibly gave me an
enema they searched my body with their
hands and took pictures of me naked i
was blindfolded and shackled someone put
a diaper on me and secured it with duct
tape
during questioning khan said he was hung
from his wrist with shackled feet barely
touching the floor the interrogators
left the room as i screamed in pain and
tried to support my weight
calling the cia facility the american
torture place khan said interrogators
went further submerging his body in an
ice bath as i struggled against drowning
then khan claimed he was sexually
assaulted while i was hanging naked
today was historic katya justin has been
representing khan as his attorney for at
least 11 years she says it took courage
for her client to give his account of
what he endured it was
very detailed and emotional and
really laid bare
the sadistic treatment that he
experienced at the hands of the cia
over a three-year period khan was
interrogated at multiple cia sites in
protest khan began hunger strikes and
claimed he was later force-fed as part
of a plea deal which included a decade
of cooperation with the government khan
admitted he joined al qaeda after his
mother's death and his father went into
debt
khan volunteered his services to khali
sheikh mohammed after 9 11 knowing he
was behind those attacks and discussed
potential plots poisoning water
reservoirs and targeting american gas
stations ton told the court i did what i
did i don't deny it i accept
responsibility and have tried to atone
for my actions under the bush
administration coley stimpson ran
detainee affairs when the men were
transferred in 2006 from the c.i.a to
the military prison at guantanamo bay as
an al qaeda terrorist
intent on seeking the death
of americans and our allies and so he's
a high value detainee he was a serious
deadly operative that's why he's
pleading guilty voluntarily at his
military commission
the continued secrecy about the
detainees treatment has been a major
impediment to resolving the remaining
guantanamo cases in his statement khan
also cast doubt on the effectiveness of
the cia program i had given up the
majority of my information from the
first day that i was captured nothing
the interrogators were doing was
effective whenever i was being tortured
i told them what i thought they wanted
to hear
under the plea agreement khan could be
transferred out of guantanamo bay to a
third country by february next year
and just to emphasize the implications
of the cia program and torture have held
up the military cases at guantanamo for
years the cia had no comment on khan's
statement but emphasized the agency shut
down its detention and interrogation
program in 2009
those details are disturbing indeed
catherine thank you